how's gone my name is Peralta back
welcome back to another episode of happy
woods
we're gonna start up from the table to
the but save your trend yeah slap that
ah son yep mr. shares there and I have a
foot for them to stay alive this
hospital
no what the hell what the hell is this
gonna have a [ __ ] bones coming
oh maybe those are his legs I guess all
right don't die
I want your sweet ass oh [ __ ] falling
off okay I expected more to be honest
alright epic run all right I guess I can
do this I play some money anyway
god damn you piece of [ __ ] you die so
easily slide that [ __ ] you okay son
okay how you in [ __ ] tot woah the lag
about lag about like a eating my own leg
oh wow eating my dead son's dick well
bike take me oh yeah first good bike ah
thank you bike oh yeah again again odd
bike come here ah okay Pokemon Balto
prepares for it
okay come on ways to poke balls there we
go um three balls give me the balls iLab
boss I mean poke balls whatever
- boss not deaf ah
two more boss I know how this way yeah
[Music]
a pretty car token God get that token to
win dad rules
[ __ ] yeah I wrote sit down boy okay ah
you offended my arms what I'm gonna wear
you as a backpack boy shut up I'll wear
whatever the [ __ ] I want
it's called fashion [ __ ] shut up and be
my backpack
I'll hump the bike otherwise shut up
that's right that's all talk about
broken or talked to some of the cares
anyways what get the hidden token - it's
at all [ __ ] easy I'll show you all
right I'll show you bye well that's the
point of that take me son what the hell
all right you go first son I don't care
just go Hey
dammit god dammit
the shame whoa okay sad is just you and
me watermelon no no no what a minute
well bye-bye you dry Josh [ __ ]
traitor I thought you were waiting me
bike [ __ ] lame oh here we go there we
go that's [ __ ] easy
Tomkins they are you better not touch a
pineapple bike I thought you were bro
man [ __ ] do you know about bikes and
things that talk all right take care
put doubt in my [ __ ] bye let's rock
hobo son well that can only be good
that's explains Oh what the hell [ __ ]
faster you little [ __ ] what the hell
that even make sense [ __ ] off
how does that penis thing come back here
a penis thing don't you leave without me
penis thing and coming after your penis
I'll pumpkin come on speed bait
lightning come on that did nothing okay
let's do it again
[ __ ] radio ah right now
go let's miss a grad come on give me
something
ah there we go got your little [ __ ] ah
run faster you whatever you [ __ ] you I
hump this radio Edna meanwhile [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ]
oh I'm driving now no I hate I won't
slow down a little bit now I'm driving
this is how bad as people drives you
seen action god mud yeah alright that's
pretty good hey how's it going brahs
this is gonna be a really weird I have
to sorta I was just editing in this one
and I realized it was only six minutes
so let's do some more happy wheels
pretty good because I actually wanted to
play Hey another thing fast
alright let's do that come on man you
can load ah [ __ ] dad down god sad about
bike are you okay back there
you became stop kicking me what the hell
are you doing by God Davin bike is
taking me again oh god damn you look at
my age here you haven't sent repeaters
what it's called now eat my bone
ah oh no you don't have a vajayjay right
[ __ ] yeah why did I do that
ah
but to have it's right in my penis come
on far away not your brow brow all right
hell is this start doing it Mike come on
I'm solid place get off me
yeah all right so let's forget all right
damn it not to make sure I like it all
right good for you but there's a twist
you're going to have oh [ __ ]
I'm going to hell oh come on man
not enough of this bull don't stop all
right keep popping God I did not expect
that one [ __ ] I keep forgetting oh yes
so happy totally happy all right now we
lose speed here there's a problem
oh wow a clutch Tango's - bro - later
[ __ ] whoa whoa I dumped that [ __ ]
that's how I roll don't need legs the
right bicycle all right
come on don't tease me don't tease me
don't do that nipples rubbing time yeah
you were like oh like about done wet
your pants
someone say anything they know us all
right I don't know but it's [ __ ]
awesome I just came to tell you that
your everybody yeah yeah that's right
yeah [ __ ] yeah
my life riding bike like a motorbike
without - god damn it got me so sad by
bike it's a [ __ ] traitor
alright seriously I need it [ __ ]
[ __ ] sword oh not a problem not a
problem not a problem what is this oh
[ __ ] off
think fast oh [ __ ] just kidding whoa yes
alright
that was a pretty cool app I did enjoyed
quite a lot man but if go keep her in it
no no daddy you're cheating let's hold
hands let's just do it let's hold hands
that's right I want the ball I want that
MA just hold hands and don't step in my
face play just brought the bar do you
always on posi okay alright here we go
blockage blockage you're not gonna get
through all right you might have scored
great idea [ __ ] Bali's brother yeah I
can't [ __ ] do it
come that stop what you're walking over
me bad sportsmanship man all right
mister share what the hell are you doing
up there hey whatever man just come here
give me a hug come on I got your back I
tricked ya betch now your dad I kick you
you're not dead actually I'm I'm doing
something okay let's do that it counts
on the edge of the [ __ ] thing instead
I don't know oh god I get back how do I
stand on - come on that is not what I
would do if I was a goalkeeper I think
yes yes oh you blow me if you want to
score it I'm talking to the ball of
cards come on [ __ ] your man [ __ ] you man
you want to score yes
[ __ ]
kiss my feet that's right that's right
that's how I roll
now that's right back up I'm backing up
back in that back in America no because
my daddy taught me good and I can do it
out there and I'm like oh my god
Sasquatch Ram poche puja page [ __ ] [ __ ]
me shut up
we're dead okay just deal with it whoa
Thank You Sasquatch thank you don't
worry bro I got your back can that badge
yeah
why are you crying for a penny all right
yeah it's okay I only got you all right
thank you
are you okay back there whoa you okay I
came over it come on man can you batter
in there
BAM nice flying man BAM that's the style
you yeah
whoa something happen honey are you okay
all right nice boat ride would don't
sink bro damn you scare me bro I had
palm tree and a coin and a victory and I
did makes me happy but anyway sorry if
this was kind of weird episode of
probably still enjoyable I can barely do
Dan enjoy it and subscribe to come bro
today and I'll see you next episode over
ere I'm a dancer and I love doing
everything that I do for you both so as
always I got a push that's gonna punch
you I used to joke the last time too
I know there was one guy though I saw
you like what what is he doing is he
gonna punch